hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Incredibles to review
I'll be sure to rank this on my list of
Pixar sequels because I think it does
work really well as a Pixar sequel but
while they were on the press tour they
did make a lot of jokes about how kids
today have absolutely no familiarity
with the brand like he was 14 years ago
so most of the little kids that went to
see the first movie are actually
graduating high school in college right
now like that's how long it's been if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a bunch of big movie stuff
happening this summer but all in all
like I said great Pixar sequel not quite
as good as the first film in my
imagination but that was one of the best
Pixar films of all time and it's still
one of my favorite superhero movies in
general animated or live-action it
skewered the superhero genre a long time
before Deadpool ever came to the scene
no capes
speaking of which Edna in jack-jack
probably the best pairing from this film
so part of the fun of the Incredibles
film is seeing the family fight together
make as many Fantastic Four jokes as you
want probably one of the best fantastic
for movies even though it's not called
Fantastic Four I don't consider it a big
knock to say that the plot is very
familiar it follows the same paradigm as
the first film all the trailers have
spelt that out except this time it's mr.
incredible that has to stay home with
the kids the biggest criticisms that I
had about it were the ending in general
like it didn't ruin the film but the
ending was a little bit silly in the
fact that there wasn't as much of the
family together as I expected like I
don't consider it a spoiler to say that
yeah there's a lot of pairings that
happen in the film part of the fun of
the film is seeing how they use their
powers together but when you see them on
screen like they kind of build this as a
family movie what you actually get from
that in the film isn't quite what they
were selling so I wouldn't call the
trailers misleading in that sense it's
just that whatever the final cut of the
movie ended up being had them apart more
than they are together working as a team
Creighton Olsen Holly Hunter were great
as always
Bob Odenkirk was a lot of fun and if
you're a big breaking bad better call
solve fan Jonathan banks is also voicing
a character in the film too just to
avoid spoilers I don't want to talk too
much about Catherine Keener character
but she was interesting
for a little bit of the film like I said
though the ending didn't work quite as
well for me but it didn't ruin the film
mostly the film is actually really good
like I said very good Pixar sequel
violet and - were fun you get a little
bit more of their life outside of the
house like they do try to build the
movie out a little bit so it's not just
mr. incredible and miss incredible out
on her adventures but probably the most
fun new part of the film was Jack Jack
in him showing off all of his powers and
I'm just trying to deal with that there
was a bit more samuel l.jackson I think
that they tried to capitalize on how big
he's gotten with the Marvel movies so
like okay well put a bunch of Frozone in
there but he was one of the people that
joked that all the little kids that
loved him from Marvel stuff and know him
as Nick Fury weren't even born when the
first movie came out so barely anyone
knows him on the street as Frozone it's
mostly little kids parents what are the
other really big highlights of the film
was Michael Giacchino's score he always
makes amazing music for Pixar films
really any films in general he's just
really good at what he does but he does
find a way of bringing the music from
the first movie back because it was so
iconic and then weaving in some new
stuff
[Music]
so obviously the real reason to go see
this movie is just to watch all the
characters use their powers together
because even though chronologically in
their lives not a whole lot of time has
passed since the first movie they have
done a much better job of learning to
use their abilities so you don't waste a
lot of time with - and violent learning
how to sort of Punk themselves up so
they can use their abilities to their
full efforts like oh my god I can do
this
authority fully aware of what they're
capable of like all the new discovery is
through the Jack Jack character and just
the crazy number of different abilities
that he manifests it's so weird watching
this after everything that Marvel's done
in the last 10 years especially in
infinity war with the level of craziness
on screen and superheroes working
together whereas the first Incredibles
film was all about addressing the place
of superheroes in the real world like do
they belong do we even need superheroes
most of the bigger criticisms I've seen
from other critics laid mostly on that
idea like the idea that it's trying to
answer a question and like show you how
superheroes are necessary when we've
already answered that a long time ago
ten times over it's kind of a problem
for the x-men films - at this point
because Marvel has made it so that
everybody loves superheroes but you go
into an x-men film and everybody hates
mutants wants to demonize them like in
the world of The Incredibles especially
in the first film people didn't like
superheroes in fact there was that
period in history when they were
outlawed so when I talk about the film
sort of retreading plot from the first
film a lot of it has to do with the
dressing the place that superheroes hold
in the world but if you do find yourself
wondering why they waited 14 years to
make a sequel if you remember way back
to the first film if you were around
when that happened Brad Bird was pretty
adamant about not doing a sequel like he
wasn't a person that did a lot of sequel
movies but I think one of the things
that happened was is that he wanted to
direct live-action films - and he's a
great director but I think within the
Disney umbrella he had a pretty big flop
with Tomorrowland so Disney probably
told him unless you do a couple sequels
for us - movies that we know are going
to be genuine hits we're not gonna let
you do the really weird movies or the
really big live-action movies that you
want to do so I don't know that they
would ever do a third movie to this but
they've done so many toy story movies
like
doing Toy Story 4 right now - which is
also going through a whole bunch of
reworks because there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening behind the scenes with
John Lasseter but it just feels like in
general Disney is going to double down
on sequels in the future because
franchises are so much a bigger part of
studio's business models than they were
when the original movie came out so
whereas they didn't pressure him to make
a sequel way back when the first one
came out I think now it's a very
different story so I don't necessarily
think that's a bad thing as long as
whatever they do next doesn't completely
retread the same plot the way that this
one kind of hits a lot of the familiar
beats from the first film even with
those few minor faults it totally works
as a big summer blockbuster so like we
have this happening this weekend then
next week is gonna be Jurassic Park
fallen Kingdom I will do a non-spoilery
review of that soon - both of them are
really good some are big blockbuster
films with just a couple minor
complaints but overall I felt like
Incredibles 2 was probably a little bit
stronger but it just depends on what
kind of movie you're looking for ranking
this on my list of Pixar sequels the
list is really short because Pixar
doesn't make a ton of sequels yet I'm
sure in the future that's gonna change
but Toy Story 3 is still number one
probably one of the best sequels to any
movie in the history of movies like just
still an amazing movie in general
Incredibles - I would rank relatively
close to Toy Story 2 but I still give
the edge to Toy Story 2 so I'd actually
recommend that you check out some Pixar
films this weekend if you're going to
see Incredibles - especially re watching
the original film which still holds up
it's still amazing once you do have a
chance to see the movie let me know what
you think of it in the comments please
no spoilers just because this is meant
to be a non-spoilery video fun fact
though Samuel Jackson having a really
strong summer of movies between infinity
war and this infinity war just crossed
the two billion dollar box office line
we'll see how long it takes it to roar
past force awakens but what'll probably
happen is is either later this week or
early next week I'll do my non-spoilery
Jurassic world review click here for
brand new ant-man the wasp footage and
click here for that Avengers 4 Kevin
Feige teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]